okay I'm gonna try to give you a quick explanation of žižek’s critique of ideology
in about 60 seconds
um which is hard to do
but let's start because we're already 15 seconds in
first you have to understand Lacan’s formula of jouissance or desire
he says what we really want is to keep on wanting, this means that what we fear
is to become fulfilled. As long as we remain unfulfilled we remain desirious
and so we remain happy by means of not getting what we want
but aspiring to what we would like to have.
Žižek says that ideology is that which gives meaning to this wanting
it tells us what to want and how to want it, and it keeps us happy in our unhappiness
that's idealogy